PADs die and get replaced. Their IPs change. Services don't. Here's the problem. Your
front-end hardcodes a back-end PAD IP. That PAD dies, a new one starts with a different
IP, your front-end breaks. Services fix this with a stable virtual IP and DNS name. Add
a selector to match PADs by label. Kubernetes creates a cluster IP, a stable virtual address.
CubeProxy writes network rules on every node. Traffic hits the service IP. It routes to a
healthy PAD. Endpoint slices track which PADs back the service, updated automatically.
Vore service types. Cluster IP internal only. The default. Node port exposes on each node.
Port 30,000 to 32,767. Load balancer. Cloud provider creates an external load balancer.
External name maps to an external DNS name. One service, many PADs, zero hardcoded IPs.
That's how Kubernetes decouples your front-end from your back-end. Run the dark's Kubernetes services.